[Music]
let's go to
carrie in phoenix arizona what's up
carrie
hey how are you doctor john dude dancing
like i have never danced before i'm
dancing on the ceiling lionel richie
style what are you doing
i am hiding in the closet so my toddler
doesn't know
so good
so good man so what's up we'll talk
quietly so
well that's why i'm in the closet so i
can talk normal um so my husband is
currently in the police academy
um and this job is hard and we know that
we're not
we're not naive to that
but um we just want to know how we can
be proactive and preventative so we both
can have a mentally healthy
experience with this and it can be
positive for our family
wow
so why in the world
would anybody join the police force
right now
my husband wants to make a difference he
wants to be the good out there he's seen
the miracles that police officers can
provide for the people and he wants to
be a part of it he hates sitting behind
a desk and he wanted a job that had
purpose what a stud man what a great man
and what a great
partner that you are walking alongside
him it's incredible incredible okay
number one thank you for
your service really number two thank you
for asking these questions before so you
guys have already experienced something
you all thought you knew what it was
gonna be then he goes to academy
and academy's
you know shocking all a little bit
walk me through what you guys are now
like you're feeling the rattling and
this job hasn't even started so
what are y'all experiencing already
that's making you go oh
ho what have we done
um i mean we're there's no regret at all
we are 110 after this
part of it i think is is seeing all the
unrest that's out there is we don't want
um we want we know that it's not all
going to be
unicorns and butterflies and great
experiences
but we know that it can be a
a positive experience and so that's part
of it is seeing all of that so we just
knew going into it
um
it i think part of it too is my husband
has interacted with some people where
he's like wow not like some cops really
they have a hard time and they kind of
can
sometimes not stay as positive
and uplifting as people or they they end
up
we went to a family night and they're
like yeah a lot of cops end up divorced
and you know so it's just kind of has
the
uh depressing
around it um and so it's it's not that
we've necessarily had anything happen we
just hear about a lot of this and we
want to be able to come out on top and
with an intact marriage and
um and have learned and grown from it
and not just suffered through it you are
making my heart full that's so wise it's
so good for both of you for your
community phoenix is lucky to have a
couple like you too okay
so i'm gonna give you a lot and some of
this is bait like i grew up in the house
of a homicide detective and a swat guy
okay so this is this is my family and
i've worked with police officers behind
closed doors for years and even some
research here so
i'm gonna give you a lot
and i'll throw it at you and you may not
even have a pen in the closet in the
dark where you're sitting hiding from
your little one but um you can just go
back and check this story out and by the
way for those who are listening this
applies not just to police officers this
applies to
new lawyers who are married this applies
to
nurses and nurse practitioners and new
physicians this applies to young
business owners
anybody who's put in a really stressful
situation with a young marriage and
little kids
it's easy for the wheels to start
rattling early on and if you don't deal
with it preventatively prophylactically
man like you said you talked to grizzled
exhausted old police officers i'm on
wife number three they keep her and you
think oh my gosh is this our destiny no
it's not it's not but you gotta start
young you gotta start soon so proud of
you okay
here's the two big ones for you okay
okay
never again
turn on the news or social media about
police officers
okay never again
over
you will get the information you need
about what's going on in your local
community in your local state from your
husband and from your friends
and that will be enough
okay there is a
narrative
on one side of the equation that police
are infallible and perfect and we should
all bow
and that's inaccurate and false
and there's a narrative on the other
side that all police are evil and
ridiculous and awful and that is absurd
and
just intractably false right
the goal of all that media is not to
pass along information that's true about
what's happening in the state of
policing in america the goal of that
information is to get your heart rate up
on either side of the equation to get
you fired up to get you to post back to
get you to keep clicking
and so as someone who loves a police
officer nobody will have more
information more on source than you
so you don't need them
opt out okay okay okay so be intentional
about that here's the second thing
there will come a season if it hasn't
already that every time your phone rings
or there's a knock on your door
you're instantly going to go to worst
case scenario
my mom told me when i was 18 19 i wanted
to go to fbi and she said i'm asking you
as your mom
not to do that
and i said why she said well i'm
thinking about your future wife and when
you're 18 19 you're like whatever
and she said
every day of my life for the last 30
years
i your dad leaves and i think he may not
come home today
that's how the wheels are written that's
how all the information is stored in the
special fireproof box that every police
officer has in their home every day they
go to work they may not come home
and what i didn't understand was that
two people carry that
both the officer and the hardest part of
this is not knowing even the academy
it's not his life's on the line but i
never know how the day went i never know
if he passed his classes i i never know
anything about it
and it's been hard to not have anxiety
over that yes so here's what i want you
to do i want you to carry a journal with
you keep it in your purse keep it by
your side use your notes app
and when you get these stories that pop
in your head just write them down
write them down because you can't do
anything about them
and so we're going to write them down
and then i'm going to move on about my
day
and that sounds ridiculous and it's not
going to stop it initially over time
your body will recognize oh she's in
control of these thoughts she's control
of these stories there's no reason to
get worked up
and we're gonna let that breathe
okay
so those are your two number three for
you you have to have friends that aren't
cops wives
okay
you're gonna have to be hyper
intentional about that
your world will begin to skew everything
police and all police deal with all day
long is everybody else's worst case
scenarios
nobody calls the police just to invite
them to their house to to give them
gifts we should do that
but we don't and so over time it's it's
common and it's normal for a police
officer who's running the beat 12 hours
a day
five twelves a week or whatever shifts
they're running
to
get a different view of the world
than is reality
okay when i say reality statistical
aggregation their reality is very very
real and when you hang out with wives
like that then it's all about
and you i want you to have people who
bring sunshine and joy into your life
okay
okay all right now here's what y'all can
do together
and this is super huge and this is all
about one word intentionality okay and
another word routine and another word
consistency that's three words
all right intentionality routine and
consistency
commit to come hell or high water come
what may
starting today you and your husband are
gonna have mental physical spiritual and
relational connectivity every day
make that part of your thing those
things could all be one minute each
it'd be better if they weren't
but if you i want you guys to build in
practices together that might be going
for a walk together and saying nothing
that might be y'all just do 10 push-ups
together that's it
it might be sex and intimacy it might be
y'all go to the gym to get i don't know
what it is i don't know what what your
schedule allows if you're working you
got kids all that stuff
but you got to have some some physical
connectivity
got to be cement you'll have to have a
time to talk to one another every single
day how are you and how are you
cops are notorious for trying to fix
everybody around them because that's
what they get called in to do every day
she's being mean to me and he tried to
punch me and the cop has to go solve
that problem as a math problem that does
not work with wife and kids
or with husbands and kids right so he
needs to sit down and listen to your day
you may want to read him your journal
you ask your questions that popped up
or just say here's what happened today
and his only response can be thank you
so much for sharing i'm so glad you're
in this with me
and here's a fun story that happened
today
do you like hearing has he started doing
ride-alongs yet
um i think it starts out two weeks okay
so when i was
running around at night
in some of the most bonker situations
ever
i learned really quick
and i was not a police officer i was
on the payroll i was running adjunct to
them they were doing the hard stuff and
i was showing up with as a victim
services guy
i learned real real quick
those stories the things i was seeing
and experiencing
my wife did not need to hear
and i had to make sure i had other
places to go for me that was a counselor
for me that was a couple of close
friends for me that was a supervisor dr
andy young who was world class one of
the best ever ever
um your husband's gonna have to have
places where he can talk about what he
has seen what he has experienced it's
not you
you are not a trash can for what happens
and
i also went too far
and i completely cut my wife out of
these what i was experiencing
and we found ourselves two inches apart
on the couch and 5 000 miles away from
each other
right so there's got to be some sort of
hey i saw something really hard and dark
last night that's messing with me and i
don't i i'm not into talking tonight can
we just hold hands and watch the office
that has to be a language y'all carry
with each other okay
and you're gonna be like all right well
tell me what happened and he may tell
you the first time you're like well
that's the last time i wanna hear about
that story right
and
um
and i'm talking about stories that you
we don't even imagine we couldn't even i
would not even even known that some of
that stuff was real until i saw it with
my own eyes
and to say it out loud
because you've seen it people around you
man
good grief we've been i mean we've had
meetings with james
it's like oh yeah this happened one time
and the whole i look around the whole
room it's just staring at me like what
what are you talking about and so you're
gonna have to know where what you can
handle what you don't want to handle
it's not a matter of your weakness not a
matter if you love him anything like
that it's a matter of we're gonna keep
this thing moving forward and then a
weekly routine never miss check-ins
together what does calendar look like
what's the status of your heart look
like
hey we haven't slept together in two
weeks we're going to put that on the
calendar because that's got to stay a
priority for us we haven't gone on a
date in 18 months because we have little
kids and i'm hiding in closets now we're
gonna have to make that stuff a priority
even when you're tired even when he's
tired y'all gotta figure out ways that
y'all can connect
especially in the beginning
is that cool when he yeah and when he
does have the traumatic experiences is
talking to a counselor the best thing to
do are there other things he could do to
work through it so that he doesn't come
home and take it out on
and our kids
the
the come home and take it out on our
kids is a it's a myth and when i say
it's a myth that does happen but just
because you see and experience hard
things doesn't mean the kids are gonna
get it so everybody deals with it
differently i'm equally concerned about
dads who come home with that kind of
stuff and check out they just completely
unplug and check out
as i am with dads who come home and yell
and scream a lot
both of those things are traumatizing
especially the kids and especially the
spouses and so i'm less concerned with
he needs to do this thing
if he discharges his weapon
at somebody and hits them he will have
to go talk to somebody
um i'm more concerned with you guys
having a marriage counselor that y'all
can talk to regularly once a month
now that we've gone through that's
awesome and making sure y'all are
communicating together he just has to
have some sort of process and the thing
i told you about the mental physical
spiritual relational
that will give him rhythm and routine
and rhythm and routine and
intentionality creates resilience
and so when he these things happen
there is a
trampoline style floor he can land on
the landing doesn't smash him
right and the landing it gives him a
bounce so he can come back
and if you don't have those things
then when the first big one happens the
first time you walk into a room and see
multiple dead people and multiple
there's blood everywhere i mean when you
see some of that stuff
you got you hit the concrete right and
there's there's no bouncing back and
then the only thing to make that feel
better is another drink or texting an
old girlfriend or whatever the thing is
right that ends up with divorce and
divorce and divorce and divorce and
divorce so it's setting those things up
here's the final thing i want to pass
along to you guys this is going to sound
gross what i'm about to say
but i'm excited
you're a mom of a toddler there is no
such thing as gross for you
not gross in the
poop and pee kind of way but gross in it
feels transactional
i want y'all and this is from the great
therapist terry real who's going to be
on our show in a few i'm super excited
terry says an important thing to do is
to ask your husband
what needs of yours
can i meet
so that you can be available to meet my
needs
and that feels gross because it feels
roi
i'll scratch your back if you scratch
mine
and out of the gate it feels yucky
like all right what are the five things
you i i just have to do for you so that
you will plug back in and then he is
instantly going all right you do those
five things i'm going to plug in and
these 12 things and
what we're doing is we're practicing
this ons and offs
what are the things that turn on this
home for you
that make this place safe for you that
make you
um feel sexual and desired that make you
laugh and that bring you joy you can
walk into your home and your shoulders
drop
i'm talking like in my house you know
what it is it's that when my wife is
gone and she's coming home in the
evening that the front porch lights are
on i don't know why that is but that's a
thing
and she sees those lights because my
driveway's really far into the woods
and she says she'll get tears in her
eyes as she drives up the driveway
knowing the home is to be warm it's
going to be safe and that people are
waiting for to come home
in a million years if you had said write
down ways to
make your wife feel safe and loved i'd
not never have written down turn the
front porch lights on right so your you
and your husband are gonna sit down and
make a list what are things you need
from me
and there may be days that you circle
back to him and say hey you told me that
sex was important to you and we're on
week two
we need to do this and it's gonna sound
like hey you need to get your butt out
and mow the yard it's gonna feel like
that
but we are
leaning into what does he need and he's
gonna lean into what does she need in in
short order this becomes a way of being
i'm walking into my home looking
scanning the room not for
what's out of place around here i'm
skiing the room for how can i best love
my kids and my wife right this second
and my wife has already thought through
that too and so i walk in and my
shoulders drop and then her shoulders
drop and now we're meeting each other in
a vulnerable
connected way
dude it changes everything
what's hard for police officers is when
they come home
and they're back in another tent
situation because they've been tense all
day
and what's hard for a wife is when she's
been tense and running around our spouse
i mean husband sue
and then a husband comes home or the
wife comes home who's a police officer
and they're tense and then now the whole
house is tense right so that tension
works but let's just let that crap out
by saying
what do you need i'm gonna make it
happen but here's what i need to we're
gonna be open and we're gonna be honest
about that how does that sound
that sounds great thank you so much you
are
awesome i've talked at you like big time
for like 20 straight minutes without
even breathing i'm super passionate
about this because i know this if police
officers have
safe homes then our communities are
safer if they've got deep plugged in
connected relationships all of us win
and i know if things are messy at home
in any job things are messy at work i
can't be whole if i'm not whole at home
right can i just tell you carrie
you know how old are you
i'm 27.
they don't make them like you you're
incredible and i'm grateful for you
thank you for real just even having this
phone call even thinking down the line
so great and make sure he's got some
friends that aren't police officers too
okay
okay drag him along to your weird stuff
he's going to want to hang out with cops
and it's going to be cops and cops and
cops and i'm talking to you lawyers and
lawyers and lawyers and doctors and
doctors have some friends that do other
things
two of my closest friends one's a ceo of
a of a
lawn care company now after being the
chief information officer at some fancy
tech companies another one of my great
friends sells oil he's a lube salesman
not that we make any jokes about that
and one of my other great friends is a
uh
caleb works at napa auto parts i've got
another buddy who's and craig's a banker
and everybody who works at hvac company
and i'm a freaking youtuber you know we
talk about everything everything
it's incredible